So the plan for today
um as I mentioned in the previous
lecture we're going to try to start with
the basics and so this means that uh
today we'll be talking about methods
that were starting to be developed in
the ancient times of the 1990s
and uh then starting I think uh next
week we'll get into more uh
newer stuff
that said even today we'll start to talk
about a case study of a real real
problem that's quite relevant today and
is from a very modern research paper
and by the end of the lecture the goals
is to really try to convey what
multitask learning is and what the key
design choices are when trying to build
these multitask systems in practice
awesome so um let's start off with some
notation so uh we'll start off with
something like a neural network it could
be a convolutional network like the one
shown here or some other neural network
and we'll denote the input as X and the
label or output is y
for example our input might be an image
like an image of a tiger here and the
label might be a classification of that
tiger it might be an image
classification problem or maybe
something more interesting like trying
to classify what to do if you see
something like this
and alternatively instead of being an
image it could be something like the
title of a paper in this case you
probably wouldn't use a convolutional
network you would probably use something
like a Transformer if you're trendy or
if you're a bit older maybe an lstm
and the label could be something like
the length of the paper and so in this
case uh if it was the length of the
paper this might be more of a regression
problem rather than a discrete
classification problem
now we'll refer to the parameters of the
neural network typically with Theta and
so this will correspond to all of the
parameters of that neural network you
can think of it as a vector that
basically flattens each of these weight
matrices and appends them into a single
very large Vector this may have millions
of values in this vector
and we can then refer to the function
represented by this neural network as F
which will give us a distribution over y
given the input X parametrized by Theta
um so this should follow fairly standard
notation that you may have seen before
now in single task supervised learning
we will be given some form of data set
which has input output pairs so a number
of examples of images like the tiger and
labels like the options on the right
and then we will Define a loss function
that tells us how good is that model at
performing that task
and our goal will be to find the
parameters that minimize that loss
function so try to find the parameter
setting of one of these neural networks
such that we do well on a classification
problem for example
um and so a typical form of this loss
function might be something like
negative log likelihood
this would look something like this
where we're measuring the likelihood
that F assigns to a given label given X
and then negating that because typically
loss functions are things that we
minimize and then trying to minimize the
negative probability of the label given
the input
uh and this kind of Vlog likelihood loss
this is equivalent to something like a
cross-entropy loss or a mean squared
error loss um that you may have seen in
uh in other machine learning courses
cool um so that should mostly be review
for folks
um now how do we go from single test
learning to multitask learning
um for that we need to figure out
actually what is a task what does it
mean to be a task
we defined what a task is in the
previous lecture but we're going to
cover a task more formally this time
and in particular in the context of this
course we'll think about a task as a set
of three things
a distribution over x a distribution
over y given X and a loss function
and so you can think of these as the
distribution that generates the data
and the reason why that we're gonna We
want to Define it something like this is
that we want to be able to say whether
or not the network is doing well at a
task
and doing well at a task is a little bit
different than doing well on a data set
and uh in particular you could have
something that does really really well
on a training data set but doesn't
actually generalize to other examples
for that task
and therefore by defining a task as the
data generating distributions and the
corresponding loss function for that
task
we can then
um
capture Notions of how well it's
actually doing on that task in general
so we can have corresponding data sets
that are sampled from these underlying
distributions like the training set and
the test set
and note that here I'm using I to like
index into the task so for task I it has
these two distributions in this loss
function and um and it has data sets
that are sampled from these
distributions
um in practice you won't have any any
sort of access to these ground trees
data generating distributions
you'll generally only have access to the
corresponding data sets
um and then also in the future slides
I'll generally use di as shorthand for
Di train um just because typically we
will refer to the training data set a
lot and it can be convenient to drop off
the the TR
uth Okay so
that is how we'll Define the task
and now let's look at some examples of
different multitask learning problems
so generally a multitask learning
problem is one where we're our goal
isn't just to solve one task but to
solve a set of tasks
and the tasks could vary in different
ways so in something like multitask
classification
the loss function will probably be the
same across all the tasks it will
probably just be the cross-entropy loss
and for example this could be something
where we want to be able to recognize
handwriting in different languages so
each language will correspond to a
different task
uh and you could have a data set that
looks like this this is actually the
Omni glot data set and you have uh
different alphabets
or different languages and so
in this case you're going to have a
different P of X distribution a
different P of Y given X distribution
because the characters themselves will
look different and also the label given
those characters will be different for
different languages
but the underlying loss function will be
the same because it's all still a
classification problem
as another example of this kind of
multitask classification problem you
could also have a personalized spam
filter where different tasks correspond
to different people and different people
will receive different kinds of spam and
they will also have different
preferences for what is spam and what's
not spam and so it will also in this
case have a different distribution over
X and a different distribution over y
given X but yet again the same loss
function
so
um that's multitask classification we
could also consider a scenario where
both P of X and the loss function are
same are the same across these tasks and
the only thing that differs is y given X
in a case like this you could think of
face attribute recognition as an example
of this where one task is maybe to
detect if someone has black hair or
brown hair or blonde hair or white hair
and a different task is to predict their
eye color
um in this case all the images are the
same you just have different
distributions of your labels
so you can the question was it can mult
can image net be considered multi-label
learning and
I guess the thing that really
differentiates multi-label learning here
and something like image.classification
is
at least the way that imagenet
classification is framed
there's only one label that is correct
um and the thing that's different here
is that
um you actually have a different set of
labels and so for example someone can
have both brown hair and brown eyes or
they could have
um blonde hair and brown eyes for
example and so you actually have
different sets of labels itself and
that's
um that's like the key differentiating
factor and so in general it's something
like imagenet classification would be
considered a single test problem that
said you can also frame things like
imagenet as multi-label problems because
oftentimes there are actually more than
one thing in an image and you may
actually want to classify all the things
in the in the image rather than just one
thing
all right
another example of multi-label learning
is something like scene understanding
where you have an image you have images
of lots of different 3D scenes and one
task is to predict the depth one task is
to predict key points in the image and
another task is to predict the surface
normals in in that scene and so this is
again an example where actually all the
images in the data set are the same the
only thing that's different is the
different labels
um so these are a couple kind of
instantiations of multitask learning
problems
um there's also scenarios where the loss
function might vary as well so in both
of these examples these are settings
where the loss function isn't changing
but you could also have scenarios where
for example some of your labels are
continuous and some of your labels are
discrete and you use a a mean squared
error loss function for the The
Continuous and a cross-entropy loss
function for the discrete labels
or you might have multiple metrics that
you care about and you want to optimize
those objectives simultaneously
cool um so the pause here is there any
questions on kind of the the setup
before we get into actually solving
these multitask problems yeah
so for the last time he said like the
task should share some structure so that
should actually mean my expectations
here are getting offensive
if they are different languages
yeah those are great questions so the
question was
um last lecture we were talking about
how the task should share some structure
does that mean that they should share
the loss function or share let's show
you like one of these three things and
what I meant by a structure in that
first lecture is something a little bit
more abstract so these are three very
concrete things and you can actually
have tasks that differ in all three of
these things but still have a lot of
common structure
um and so I guess structure is something
that's a little bit more abstract we can
think of we'll come back to a little bit
more to what structure is when we get to
some of the Bayesian perspective on it
um but I guess as one example uh you
could imagine something like uh the per
language handwriting recognition these
tasks have a lot of shared structure
intuitively in the sense that they
um recognizing characters is uh
implicitly about recognizing the shape
of the the handwriting but you could
also have a version of this that has
different loss functions because maybe
in one case one of your loss functions
is is more continuous because maybe some
of the digits are some of the characters
are actually like numerical values
rather than characters and something
like that you may actually have
different loss functions while still
having a lot of shared structure
cool
um so now let's get into actually
learning networks that solve multitask
learning problems so
the first thing that we generally need
to do in multitask learning problems is
to tell the neural network what the task
is
and we'll do this with what I'll call a
task descriptor which will denote as z i
and we'll pass this into the network in
some way or another and so the function
will no longer be modeling y given X but
actually modeling y given X comma z i
um and so
let's kind of actually
better understand what this task
descriptor might be so say that you're a
very diligent grad student and you were
assigned a bunch of papers to review
and you want to understand how long it's
going to take you to review these papers
so you may be one of your tasks might be
to take the title of the paper and
predict the length of the paper
the second task is maybe maybe you want
to get an initial summary of the paper
before reviewing it and so you the
second task is to predict a summary of
the paper
uh and maybe the third task is uh you're
getting maybe a little bit too lazy and
you just want to write the paper review
for you
so we have three tasks here and the task
descriptor in this case could be a few
different things
um the first thing is it could just be a
one-hot encoding of the task index
and in this case what this means is that
we just have a one hot Vector one hot
Vector is just something that uh looks
like this where we're encoding an
integer in um in Vector form where for
example the integer one will be denoted
with a one in the first position and
zero on the other two the integer two
will be denoted as with the one in the
second position and for the third task
the task descriptor would be something
like this
um so this would be an example the
simplest possible way that we could tell
the network what the task is so this
would be telling it that the task is the
first one the second one and the third
one
but we can also do something a little
bit more creative so we could for
example give it a language description
of what we want it to do so we could
tell it give me a summary tell me the
length of the paper Give me a review
um and so Z could actually be a natural
language string of what the task is as
well
so some other examples it really could
just be whatever metadata you have about
the tasks so it could be
um not really in this example but if you
have an example where different tasks
are different people they can correspond
to different attributes of those users
um if you have an example where like
this one where you have some sort of
natural description of what the task is
then you could condition on that
um you may also have some domains where
you have a more formal specification of
what the task is and you could also try
to pass that into the network to tell it
what the task is
cool
um so now that we've
defined now that we've told the network
what what the task is we can also
formulate the objective
so uh the basic way to formulate the
objective is actually what we covered in
the previous lectures we just sum up the
loss functions for each of the tasks so
Li here is Computing the loss function
of the network on the training data set
for that task then we'll sum up over all
of the t-tasks that we have and try to
minimize the loss function minimize the
parameters of our neural network
um
over the sum of loss functions yeah
very much the same type same as like
prompting the model uh like the recent
work that's been done yeah so you can
think of the task descriptor as a form
of prompt you typically wouldn't think
of something like this as a prompt um
but yeah it basically can be a prompt or
it could be something a little bit more
basic
the um a set of XY Pairs and so what
exactly were you asking
so you'll have different data sets for
different tasks in in general so
um
as we talked about before the each task
will be defined by its own data
generating distribution and then the
training data set is drawn from that
that data generating distribution you
may have cases where kind of P of X is
the same across tasks and so in that
case all of the x's in your data set may
be identical
um but then then even in those cases the
Y's will be different for different
tasks and in general these training data
sets will be different across tasks
does that answer your question
is
foreign
you're asking if the data
Center
previous
um so I mentioned here that for example
the X the images might all be the same
across tasks
um so in this example uh in scene
understanding the images will all be
potentially identical across tasks but
the labels will be different so the
labels for the depth task correspond to
the depth annotations the labels for the
normals tasks correspond to something
like this and so forth
yeah
um you mentioned a task to step first
um there are an awful data sets where
you don't get the task description what
happens then
yeah so you might have a data set where
you don't have the task descriptor in
that case you can just
um go with the basic kind of one hot
encoding um assuming that you at least
have some sort of differentiation
between the tasks it's also possible
that in some cases you might be able to
tell what the task is just from the
input
if if P of X is different across tasks
um you might just be able to tell
without a form of task descriptor but in
general
um in general in multitask learning
we're going to assume that we at least
have some separate data sets for each
task
[Music]
yeah so we'll talk about that next
cool so I think that we can just
transition
um into the next part so
this is the um kind of the basic setup
but there's still a lot of design
choices to make here we needed to sign
the model the objective and the
optimization process like what was just
asked we need to figure out how do we
actually pass in zi into the network
we also need to figure out
um if we should use this vanilla
objective or if we can use something a
little bit more sophisticated and also
how do we go about optimizing this
objective
so we'll talk about each of these design
choices one by one uh and we'll start
with the model so we'll start by trying
to think about how can the model be
conditioned on zi and what parameters of
the model should be shared across tasks
versus separate
cool um so now let's assume that zi is a
one hot index like what we talked about
before
um I have a question for for all of you
which is um
how should we choose to condition the
network on this one hot Vector in a way
that we'll try to share as little as
possible
and what I mean by this is we want to
have as few of the parameters
for different tasks be shared we want to
basically get as close as possible just
training completely separate neural
networks on each task
does anyone have any thoughts yeah
all right finding good loss functions
can you explain a little bit more
yeah the question is
um if we assume that zi is just a one
hot Vector for each of the tasks
um how should we condition the network
on zi such that the network is sharing
as little as possible such that we are
as close as possible to just training
completely different neural networks
yeah I guess we could just have like a
switch statement for each of the
different conditions so if it is if
1001 that do a separate Network program
yeah exactly so um in particular what we
can do and what was suggested is you can
basically just have
different neural networks uh two
different neural networks and basically
have a switch statement have Z basically
modulate which of those networks you use
to make a prediction
um and so formally what this would look
like if Z is a one hot Vector is you
would pass say y1 is the output of the
first Network Y2 is the output of the
second Network and so forth and all of
these have separate parameters
then we can compute the output as
basically just switching between these
different outputs and so if the task is
the first task then you would output y1
if the task is the second task then you
would output Y2 and so forth
and what you get as a result of this is
that you basically this is still a
single neural network
but you get completely independently
independently trained neural networks
within the single neural network
was there a question
um and so essentially this corresponds
to having no shared parameters across
the tasks
yeah
[Music]
and then
it's performance across all it does with
as many shared parameters as possible so
that accommodation
yes exactly so in general
um this is not a great way to go about
doing multitask learning
um it's kind of one extreme and on kind
of The Other Extreme of the problem we
could share a lot more we could share
basically everything
and so what we could do instead is to
have a single neural network and
basically just um for example
concatenate Z with the with one of the
layers and in this case
if you just concatenate Z to one of the
layers and then have everything else be
normal
then um
then in this case basically all of the
parameters are shared across the tasks
um with a small exception of the the
kind of the parameters following zi
technically will not be shared across
tests but all the other parameters in
the network will be shared
um so you have these two different
extremes and there's
becomes this choice of um what what well
what should you actually do in practice
um and so
an alternative way of viewing this this
form of conditioning on zi is basically
splitting the parameters into shared
parameters into specific parameters
so
um if you split it the objective into
shared parameters into top specific
parameters we saw one example where
everything was basically top specific we
saw another example where everything was
shared you can basically formulate
rewrite the objective as something like
this which is exactly equivalent to the
previous objective the only thing that
we're doing is we're now just saying
that we
um we have
uh we basically split up our parameter
Vector into these two parts
and the thing that's useful about
writing it this way is that it really
shows us that the task specific
parameters for task I are only optimized
with respect to loss function I
and so
um those parts of the network will only
see data from one of the tasks rather
than all of the tasks
yeah
like for example and like uh the MLP
space if you just train a large language
models
yeah that's an awesome question so the
question was um
is there a constraint that in multitask
learning that we're going to be learning
all the tasks all at the same time
and in general for the purpose of this
lecture we're only going to be
considering things that we're learning
at the same time in the next lecture on
Monday we'll start talking about
transfer learning where we learn one
task and then learn another task
um and then the last lecture in the
course we're going to also talk about
lifelong learning where we are learning
a set of tasks in sequence one task and
another test and another task and so
forth
um
in general a lot of the underlying ideas
underlying multitask learning are also
applicable to the setting where you're
not learning everything at once
um
and one thing that is somewhat nice
about looking at things like this is
that you could imagine training on a few
tasks
um and that gives you maybe some good
shared parameters and then additionally
training some task specific parameters
separately after the fact
um and so things like that uh are are
often very reasonable to do
yeah
my class learning is understanding are
the links are good and they make
payments
like method is good is like to speak
about immediately do something which is
sharing is
[Music]
yeah so the question is um it seems
annoying to have to manually break this
up and figure out what should be shared
and what shouldn't be shared can we just
have it like have an algorithm figure it
out for us uh and so there are some
approaches that do something like that
um in general it's
it's um
is somewhat of a chicken and egg problem
because if you have something else
choose what to share and what not to
share then that thing that's choosing
will probably use data from all the
tasks and so that's going to be shared
across all the tasks so
um in general it's there is some there
are going to be some manual choices
regardless
um but there are some some techniques
that do something like that
yeah yeah
so the question is
um do we know anything about the kind of
the comparative rates of of different
task learning I'll briefly talk about
that when we start to talk about the
optimization process
so the next thing that I want to talk
about and specifically thinking about
breaking things into shared parameters
and task specific parameters is that
in the previous two slides we saw one
extreme of sharing nothing and we saw
one extreme of sharing everything just
based on how we condition on Zi
and one of the things I think is
interesting here is it suggests that
basically choosing how to condition the
network on zi is equivalent to choosing
how and where to share parameters
um and so
in general
um choosing how to condition on zi is
actually a very delicate choice because
you need to be careful about how much
you should be sharing versus how much
you shouldn't be sharing
um so we looked at two extremes of of
conditioning
um I want to go over two other common
choices in conditioning well actually
sort of three other common choices
so we talked about just concatenating
um the zi with the activations at one of
the layers
and so this looks something like this
where you take the the input or the
activations at one layer you take your
zi you concatenate them together and
then pass that into the network
another thing that you could do instead
of concatenating is adding together a
representation of both of them so you
could pass a z i through a linear layer
and pass the input through a linear
layer and then add them rather than
conditioning them
um and then get the resulting output
now one thing that you might notice here
is um
these are two options that seem somewhat
different
but it actually turns out that the
concatenation-based conditioning here
and the additive conditioning here are
exactly equivalent to one another
um and so
I'm curious maybe it's one thing I want
to try something new so typically I ask
people what why they're the same thing
rather than just asking you I want you
to take Maybe
one-ish minute to think about it and
then one-ish minute to talk to your
neighbor about it and then after two
minutes I'll ask you
um
I'll ask you to share why you think
they're the same thing so you can think
about it for a minute I'll tell you in a
minute to
talk to someone and yeah
foreign
okay
um cool let's come back
um does anyone want to share what they
came up with
[Music]
yeah awesome so in particular if we have
some
some input X
and some task descriptor Z we're gonna
uh if we concatenate them we'll do
something like this and have a weight
Matrix right here
and you can instead think of this weight
Matrix as having two parts
W1 and W2
um
so this is just the left half of the
Matrix this is the right half of that
Matrix and this is equivalent to W1
times X Plus W2 times Z
and so one thing that I one thing that's
kind of important in the second figure
is that actually the X and the Z are
first going through a linear layer
before you add them together
um
and uh this is exactly kind of the
additive conditioning version
and you can kind of visually see this
like right here where the red Matrix
corresponds to W1 the blue Matrix
corresponds to W2 and
yeah
when you're aware of the additive
conditioning which you have with the
network could have like more expressive
power and would possibly additive
conditioning be better than that is
um
seriously if you had a non-linearity uh
basically here
so if you had something like a
non-linearity here basically
um
yeah so something once you add non-start
adding non-linearities it does get more
expressive
um the
and yeah so if you did do have some
non-linearities on these separately it
would be a little bit more expressive
um you could also Imagine
yeah so in that case it would be a
little bit more specific
yeah
is there any computational trade-off
between the two
um in general I think that
uh I would guess that on well so I would
guess that on Modern computers
um this is better because we have very
good Matrix Vector multiplication
modules
um
but I haven't tested it myself on
Hardware
and I guess I would guess it's probably
not that significant compared to other
layers of neural networks like
convolution layers
[Music]
um
I guess
yeah I guess in both of these cases in
practice you probably won't just be like
having this literally be the output of
your network you'll probably also
continue to pass that through fully
connected layers and so forth
um and so in general
um when we talked about adding
non-linearities there I'm guessing that
wouldn't have a huge effect in terms on
the expressive power because this is a
part of a larger Network
cool
um so that was concatenation and
additive conditioning
um
two other choices that are quite common
one is to use a multi-head architecture
where you have some shared bottom layers
that are
every like all the tasks you pass in the
input through the same exact layers and
then for different tasks you have
different heads or different sets of
task specific layers
and a generalization of this that you
can consider is
multiplicative conditioning so before we
saw additive conditioning you can also
multiply the task descriptor or
representation of the task descriptor
with the activations
and so what this will look like is
basically just replace the additive
um the addition operation in the
previous equation with the dot product
or with a sorry with an element-wise
multiplication
and something like this is uh
is going to be more expressive than at
least per layer than adding and it can
actually
it could actually represent things like
the multi-head architecture
um and the reason that we can see that
is if you remember
the kind of very first example that we
looked at where we're essentially
multiplying the z i with the with the
outputs the sort of multiplication can
sort of gate the network and create
um
I basically modulate uh which layers are
used for which tasks
cool
um and so yeah in general multiplicative
conditioning is going to generalize
having independent networks and
independent heads yeah
um
tension is sort of like a task
um so insofar his attention is basically
like dot products um then then yes uh
something like attention can be uh
viewed as task specification
um any other questions
yeah
yeah where you where you multiply will
matter
um although
that said you could also Imagine like
even if you do this sort of gating at
the very beginning of the network
um you could imagine
well I guess yeah even with fully
connected layer well it's yeah the
architecture will generally Still Still
matter
um and so
it can represent certain kinds of gating
and uh
but yeah the architecture still matters
[Music]
um
so the question is if you do this sort
of multiplicative conditioning on every
single layer does that let the network
sort of figure out what to share and
what not to share
um to some extent yes I guess I should
also mention that even if the network is
sharing all the parameters and it's
getting gradients from all the tasks for
all the parameters you could also
imagine it sort of zeroing out certain
certain parts of the weights so that it
represents something more like
independent networks and so the
the network can arrive in a setting and
where where some things are being used
for only one task
um
even without
even without like a multiplicative
conditioning like thing
cool
um so we covered really the basics I
mean the basics are really either
concatenation slash additive
conditioning or multiplicative
conditioning
um and
you can have more complex choices
there's a lot of papers that consider
more complex choices although even even
just um the basic approach typically
works pretty well
now unfortunately
figuring out how you structure the
architecture and how you condition on
the network is um is a lot like just
general neural network architecture
tuning which is that it often is fairly
problem dependent and it's a little bit
more of an art uh than a science and
it's oftentimes guided more by Intuition
or knowledge of the problem as opposed
to having like a really rigorous set of
guidelines for exactly what you should
do
um that said we'll talk a little bit um
in some of the coming slides about uh
some things that can help guide that uh
that process
yeah
that we're using so if you're using like
a natural language
condition on that differently
um and also do you have any insights on
like what sort of descriptors might be
better like is the one hot better
because it's more explicit or could
knock your language would be better
includes more like nuanced yeah so there
are two questions there one is what
short descriptor should you use and the
second is is the way that you condition
the network on that descriptor
differed based off of the kind of
descriptor that you have so in general
uh for the first question the more
information you give to the network
typically the better if you give it just
a one hot Vector
these one hot vectors are orthogonal to
each other and so you're not
um you're not giving it any information
about how these tasks might relate to
one another and if you instead give it a
language description of the task where
one of the tasks is write me a story
another task is write me a poem another
task is translate between these two
tasks or between these two languages
then that will give it a little bit of
information about the similarity between
tasks because write me a story and write
me a poem those are similar sentences
and so naturally the task should be a
little bit more similar as well
um so generally the more information you
give it the better if you have access to
that information
uh and then in terms of conditioning
um I think that my my general advice
would be that multiplicative
conditioning is generally what like the
way to go because it gives you more
expressive power uh and in practice
we've seen things like attention and
multiplicative conditioning through like
feature-wise modulation to be the um at
least one of the approaches that you see
the most in um in what people do
has there been any work done on my task
embedding to accelerate how we have word
embeddings if you could have a task
embedding so it's not just like one more
factors
yeah so um the question is like can we
is there any work on getting a task
embedding
um and I should note that if you
um if you have a weight Matrix that's
going after a
um
after a uh a task descriptor then this
is going to convert that one hot Vector
into a dense vector and so in that sense
this weight the first weight Matrix that
comes after that one hot task descriptor
is going to give you an embedding of the
task and it's essentially if you learn
multitask learning from scratch then
it's going to learn these task
embeddings from scratch but
it would be interesting if we could
develop things like the notion of word
vectors but for tasks
um and one thing you could do is if you
have a natural language description
encode that into a sentence encoding and
use that representation as your task
descriptor
yeah the question is how do you
implement the multiplicative game so if
you have four tasks do you just add a
soft Max gate later over dimension for
out of the last layer yeah so um the way
that you can implement the
multiplicative gate is going to look a
lot like this so
um if the say the um
say the dimensionality of one of your
activations is um
is uh like d dimensional then what
you'll want to do is take your one hot
Vector also multiply that by a weight
Matrix so you get another D dimensional
Vector
um
so once you have two D dimensional
vectors then you'll just do element wise
multiplication uh and so you'll replace
this this plus sign with a element-wise
multiplication operation
foreign
cool
um so we've talked a lot about the
architecture the model
um now let's talk about the actual
objective so earlier on WE formulated
this multitask this vanilla multitask
learning objective
but in many cases we may want to weight
the tasks differently so we may want to
formulate an objective that looks like
this where we are going to assign a
higher weight to some tasks compared to
others
does anyone have any thoughts on how we
might choose the weights
yeah perhaps uh how many times you see
data for each tasks so stop that you see
more
lesser so that it's not imbalance yeah
so you could have something where you
weigh um
you would change the weight based off of
the amount of data that you have maybe
if you have a lot more data it could
actually make sense to down weight if
you have less data it may make sense to
up weight
um one thing I'll mention here is by
formulating this objective as a sum over
tasks this is already going to somewhat
normalize over the amount of data per
task
um because uh rather than if we instead
summed over the data points that we had
then that would assign higher weight to
um to tasks with more data
okay
yeah absolutely so if you have some loss
functions that are much higher in
magnitude then you may want to down
weight those and up weight loss
functions that have a lower magnitude
yeah
MTL and you see that the Network's
really struggling on a specific task
then you take away the test quicker yeah
so if you find that the model is uh
doing poorly on one task then you could
try to upweight that task and we'll
actually cover a method that will do
that automatically later on this slide
any other ideas
yeah
so there's some tasks that you care
about more than others like in some
cases maybe there's actually only one
task you care about and you just have
these other auxiliary tasks that you are
hoping might help out then you can up
weight the tasks that you care about the
most
visions
yeah so you could in some ways treat the
WIS as hyper parameters as well although
when you choose those hyper parameters
you need some overall objective to tune
them with respect to and so uh you also
and for example you could that overall
objective could be the vanilla objective
but you may also have cases where the
vanilla objective is not suitable like
when the magnitude of the losses are
different or when some tasks matter more
than others
one more
function to help a
consisting gun when it has when someone
is going to stuck in a local member or
maximum
you have a less weighted objective
than them
kind of kick it out so it'll take a
little bit more weight
[Music]
yeah so you may if you run into some
optimization challenges it could be that
actually changing the waiting AIDS and
the optimization challenges for example
maybe if you have a task that seems to
be stuck maybe if you start planning
placing all of your weight on that task
it will help push it out of that kind of
that local Optimum or something or maybe
you could if it's stuck on that task
maybe you should actually stop
optimizing and revisit it later so
um there are a number of different
approaches that you could take
um the first thing that I have listed
here is actually just based on some
importance or priority which would be
some sort of manual selection
um but there are also various heuristics
that you could use to uh to choose these
weights as well
um and the other thing that I'll mention
is you don't have to have these weights
be fixed throughout training you could
actually have them vary at different
points of training for example if you
have optimization challenges or if some
tasks are doing worse than others in the
optimization
um
and so in addition to some of the the
things that you have also adjusted and
other heuristic that some prior work has
looked at is encouraging gradients to
have similar magnitudes
um that said there's a pretty large body
of work on different heuristics that
I've looked at different different ways
of approaching this in general the
vanilla objective or manually chosen
weights is generally one of the
strongest approaches that you can take
but there has it's worth acknowledging a
lot of work that on certain problems you
can't see improvements
now the other thing the other approach
that I want to mention here which
actually came up before is you could
optimize for the task that is doing the
worst
and in particular you can formulate this
as a Minimax optimization where at each
point in training you pick the task that
has the highest loss and you update the
parameters on that task
and this is exactly going to
um basically try to normalize or
equalize the task to some extent and
this is relevant when you think that all
of the tasks matter equally
um and so
um
in particular kind of what this will
look like is if you have
um
if you have task one task two and task
three and you plot their loss value and
for example for task one your loss
values down here for task two your loss
values up here for task three your loss
values right here what this will do is
um you're going to estimate these loss
value at your current iteration of
training you'll notice that this one is
doing the worst and then you'll start
only optimizing on task two
and then after you start optimizing on
task two you'll reevaluate this uh
chances are hopefully this has gone down
a little bit maybe one of the other ones
has gone up a little bit because you
weren't optimizing on that one and then
you'll start optimizing for this one
um at the end of this process in general
you should end up with loss values that
are more similar across the three tasks
compared to if you would only optimize
the sum of them because if you optimize
the sum it might just prioritize it
might minimize the tasks that are
easiest rather than trying to maintain
equal value
uh and this can be especially useful In
fairness settings where maybe different
tasks correspond to different users or
different demographics or different
subpopulations or different geographic
regions and in those settings you want
to have similar loss values for those
different subpopulations because you
don't want to have some customers that
are getting a really great experience
and some customers that are having a
really terrible experience
or likewise some people that have a
great experience versus a terrible
experience
yeah so this in general becomes a harder
optimization problem there are also
um yeah so there are a range of
challenges with this kind of approach
um another thing that's somewhat
challenging is you need to compute what
is the worst loss
um
and it the way that you would
optimize this exactly is every single
iteration you would compute what is the
worst one and evaluating the loss
function on your entire data set may be
expensive
but there are ways to
um to approximate uh which one is the
worst one by keeping like a running
average or something like that
um and in practice it's not something
that is too hard to optimize especially
if you have a relatively small number of
tasks you have a lot of tasks that gets
a little bit trickier
yeah so in practice
um it is good good practice to normalize
your labels like your um your uh yeah
normalizer labels and and make sure your
loss functions are all on the same scale
um if you don't do something like that
or if it's difficult to do that what
this is going to do is prioritize the
loss functions that are the most
difficult or that are the highest in
magnitude
yeah so my question is about opposite or
outside if you wanna so let's say if her
objective is on a primary that's great I
mean if you want to optimize our
friendly desktop I mean many of times we
use multitask learning
so another question is how do we find
our Optical how do we configure the
objective function to decide on what
auxiliary the auxiliary tasks would be
helpful for advisory yeah so if you
really only care about like one of the
tasks for example
um then
in that case actually treating wi as a
hyper parameter makes a lot of sense
because your outer objective is I want
to do as best as possible on task one
and I want those other tasks to help me
and so
um you can manually figure out what wi
leads the lowest loss function on the
validation set for task one or you could
apply automatic hyper parameter
optimization techniques as well to do it
for you
yeah I was wondering so that
this type of um
Trying to minimize the maximum loss
um it kind of reminds me of like L1
versus O2 versus alternating Norms
um so it's possible to or have people
try to change the exponent for for the
loss like instead of just doing uh wait
times loss because you lost squared and
it's kind of like the L2 Norm of putting
everything down and I was going to be
kind of similar to the mid-maps yeah
actually that's a great question I
haven't
um I haven't come across other like
things that aren't
uh L2 or L infinity or or L1 like
something that does some other exponent
basically uh but that something like
that could be interesting to think about
and
um one of the challenges with this kind
of objective is sometimes it can be a
little bit too
pessimistic and can place a little bit
too much focus on the worst case uh and
something that is somewhere in between
L2 and L Infinity may actually mitigate
that challenge so that could be
interesting to explore
um one last thing that I'll mention
um if you're interested in digging more
into this this looks a lot like what's
called distributionally robust
optimization or um Dro
and so if you want a keyword to learn
more about it you could take a look at
that
um and the math gets quite deep you can
actually like
um there's a lot of nice guarantees that
you can get about this kind of
optimization
great um and then lastly we'll briefly
talk about uh the optimization process
itself before going into a case study
uh and I'm just going to go over the
standard optimization process that we
might do for this objective because
um in general
uh
in general it works pretty well uh
and so the basic version of this is
we'll sample a mini batch of tasks
so I mean if we only have three tasks
then we can just sample all three but if
you have a very large number of tasks
you might just sample a subset of those
tasks
then we will sample data points for each
of the tasks that we sampled so this is
going to be another mini batch
and then we can compute the loss on that
mini batch so we have each of the tasks
in our batch of tasks and then we have
the data set the mini batch data set for
that task that we computed and this will
correspond to kind of a mini batch loss
function in the multitask setting
and so once we've computed our mini
batch loss function then we can compute
the gradient of that loss function and
back propagate that into the neural
network
and apply the gradient with your
favorite Optimizer so you could use
vanilla stochastic gradient descent
perhaps with momentum or you could use
something like atom which is often used
in practice
so this basically just corresponds to
stochastic gradient descent on the
multitask objective the thing that's
probably the the most different from
that is we are going to be sampling a
mini batch of tasks and so this ensures
that the tasks are sampled uniformly
regardless of the quantities of data and
so if you have a lot more data for one
task than another task this is going to
make sure that those two tasks are still
sampled at the same rate of course if
you care a lot more about the task that
has more data then you may actually want
to do something a little bit different
than this first step
um the other thing that came up is that
the
um you may actually have loss functions
that are at different scales and if you
have a regression problem even if your
loss function is the same if it's mean
squared error if your task labels for
different tasks are at different scales
like one varies from negative five to
five another varies from negative 100 to
100 then your loss function is going to
be scaled correspondingly and so it's
good to try to normalize your labels so
that your loss functions are at the same
scale
cool
um so actually before we go into the
case study
um there's a few different challenges
that I want to bring up and this is
going to affect some of the design
choices as well
so one challenge that comes up is
negative transfer between tasks and what
negative transfer means is that
sometimes if you try to train with
multitask learning the resulting model
actually does worse than if you were to
train completely independent neural
networks
um and as one example of this you can
formulate a multitask version of The
cfar 100 data set and you can compare
the performance of a multi-head
architecture of a cross-stitch
architecture which was an architecture
proposed by some prior work and also
just independently training the models
and what we see here is actually the
independently trained model is getting
67 accuracy which is more than 10
percent higher than the multitask
learning approaches
um so why might this be the case
um this could be the case because of
optimization challenges so there might
be some interference between the tasks
they might be trying to use their
representation in different ways
or the test might be learning at
different rates and if one of them one
of the tasks is more or less converged
and one of the tasks is still learning
that may make it difficult to
um to keep on updating the network
um it could also be not an optimization
challenge but just a challenge of
limited representational capacity uh
oftentimes multitasking networks are
doing more and so they need to be larger
than if you were to just train on a
single task
so
um if you have a negative transfer uh
the natural thing to do is just try to
share less across tasks and so you can
see if you're having negative transfer
by just trying to train independently if
you're seeing that independent training
is doing better then you can just try to
make it more like independent training
um and so we saw a few different ways to
try to do that before
um by for example having a multi-head
architecture that explicitly has
different parts of the network that are
not shared at all between the tasks
[Music]
yeah so the question is are there any
unsupervised methods for telling if um
if there's going to be positive or
negative transfer
um between the tasks in general
um
I guess I'll show that in a little bit
in a minute
um but in general
you certainly without the labels of the
task you certainly can't um it's
certainly very difficult to tell if
there's going to be positive or negative
transfer ideally it'd be awesome if you
could just have a description of the
task at each of the tasks and then
something that tells you like are these
going to work well together or not uh
unfortunately I think that something
like that is nearly impossible because
it's not just going to depend on what
the task is but also the nature of the
data set the nature of the model that
you're training potentially also the
nature of the optimizer as well so
um in general these sorts of things are
very hard to tell a priority
yeah if you are getting negative
transfer and you see that
sometimes
yeah it's a great question so if you're
seeing that independent training is
doing better than your current multitask
model why not just go with the
independent networks
um it's it's very reasonable to kind of
stop there and go with the independent
networks although there are definitely
scenarios where you could still you
could get better performance with a
different architecture for example if
you started by trying to share
everything there are certainly scenarios
where training a multi-head architecture
will do a lot better than both
sharing everything and training
independently
how do I tell them
um so the question is is there a way to
tell if there's like if the tasks are
just incompatible versus did I mess up I
guess
um
the uh
in general I think it's a trial and
error process it's kind of very similar
to like trying to tell a priority if
there's going to be a negative transfer
or not
yeah
uh it's not in this bit of sharing this
could it be possible to play train from
the other stuff
yeah so another way that you could
possibly share less is to basically
pre-trade on one toss and then fine-tune
on maybe the tasks that you care more
about or something like that
um and actually this ties in a little
bit to what I had on the rest of the
slide which is that you don't actually
have to either share parameters or not
share parameters it can be a little bit
more flexible of a decision it could be
something like pre-training and
fine-tuning
um or you could have something which is
referred to as soft parameter sharing
where you actually have separate
parameters for the tasks like a
pre-trained versus fine-tune network but
perhaps you just have some soft
constraint that encourages those
parameters to be similar to one another
and the way that you would Implement
that is take the same exact objective
that you had before where you have some
set of task specific parameters perhaps
even the entire network has top specific
parameters but then try to tie them
together with a loss that encourages the
tasks the parameters of different tasks
to be similar to one another
and so there there is actually much more
of a Continuum than just sharing versus
not sharing
um
some of the benefits of this is this can
allow for kind of more fluid degrees of
parameter sharing and and things like
fine-tuning are also an example of that
um it's also worth acknowledging though
that this has some limitations because
um this introduces yet another set of
design decisions and Hyper parameters
you need to figure out how to weight
that that loss function that ties them
together
um and um and this is also going to be
more memory intensive because you have
to store separate parameters
cool
um the second challenge that you might
encounter is based almost the opposite
of um of negative transfer which is that
uh you might not actually be sharing
enough so
um if you see that you are training your
multitask learning problem but you're
actually overfitting a lot on your
problem
UM multitask learning is a form of
regularization because you're giving it
these auxiliary loss functions that
should help learn representations and if
you're seeing that you're overfitting on
your tasks then it could actually be
beneficial to try to share more than
what you're currently sharing
um and now the last challenge that I'll
come to which is um kind of related to
some questions that came up before which
is that
um generally if you have a number of
tasks and you want to determine if
you're going to see positive transfer or
negative transfer like and trying to
understand should you train all of them
together can you figure out which ones
are going to be complementary
um in general I think this is somewhat
of an open problem
and the bad news is that as I mentioned
there's no thing that will just tell you
will it work or not at the outset
there's no closed form measure of how
similar two tasks are how complementary
they are in practice
and the reason for this is that uh it
depends not just on what the tests are
but on the data set on the optimizer on
the architecture and so forth and it
could even depend on where you are in
the optimization process so for example
one task might be to pick up a fork and
skewer and another task might be to pick
up a fork in that case if you're early
on in the optimization then picking up
the fork is the first step that you need
to learn and so they might be very
complementary early on in the
optimization but then later on they may
actually be not very complementary
because one of them actually needs to do
something once you've picked up the fork
whereas the other thing doesn't need to
do anything
um this somewhat better news is that
there are some ways to try to
approximate task similarity from a
single training run rather than trying
to brute force uh and see what happens
when you um train different sets of toss
together
um and so here's one example of
something that tries to basically do a
single training run of a single
multitask Network analyze how those
tasks are similar to each other by
looking at looking at the gradients
looking at the optimization process and
then ultimately figuring out which tasks
to be grouped together and which tasks
should be trained separately
okay um so to recap
um most of the lecture
um we talked about what a task is as
these data generating distributions we
talked about how each of these tasks
have data sets
um how for the model architecture we
could have multiplicative conditioning
versus additive conditioning and that
multiplicative is a bit more general or
a bit more expressive
and then you could also try to share
more or less in your network depending
on the transfer that you observe
um we also talked a little bit about the
objective and the optimization about
choosing task weights and as well as
stratifying your mini bouches so that
you have a similar amount of data per
task in your mini batch
question
is there like a data science relation to
the success of these approaches so if
you have less data would it make more
sense to train like separate models for
each task as opposed to like a more
complex multi
-time yeah so
um
in general if you have less data per
task then multitask learning has more
potential to be beneficial because it's
a form of bringing in data from bringing
in additional data basically the data
from other tasks is being brought into
the optimization process whereas if you
have a ton of data for all of the tasks
then
um you'll probably chances are you'll
probably do well if you just train from
scratch on um on those tasks yeah
it's very very reasonable way to be
distracted by how much structure to tax
charity makes it similar usual
information but how you can like you
better be easier to quantify how well
you can create one thing for another is
there something analogous for taxes yeah
so the question is is there a way to
quantify
um the similarity between tasks and with
something like Mutual information
um and yeah so maybe I'll try to
I usually cover this a little bit later
but I'll see if I can try to cover this
in the next lecture
um basically there's a way to formulate
um to basically think of it in the
language of graphical models and think
about what are the statistical
dependencies between the um between the
data sets and the strength of those
statistical dependencies will translate
into the similarity between the tasks
awesome so in the remaining 10 minutes
I'd like to get into a case study of
where
um where people actually use multitask
learning in a real world problem
and in particular this is a paper from
some folks that work at Google
and their goal was to make
recommendations for YouTube and so they
are basically trying to figure out
what should you put in this right column
right here so
a very real real problem probably even
something that you may have encountered
yourself
uh and it's pretty cool because the
paper actually goes into a lot of detail
in um in how they actually try to solve
this problem
um so before we get into how this is a
multitask learning problem let's get
into the setup so
as input they have information about
what the user is currently watching and
they also have some features about that
user so they have features about the
video and features about the user
um and once they have that input they're
going to generate a few hundred
candidate videos
and then try to rank those candidate
videos
and then ultimately once you have a
ranking then you'll serve the top
ranking videos in that right side panel
uh the candid videos are
um are going to be pooled from multiple
candidate generation algorithms these
candidate generation algorithms are
going to use things like matching the
topic of the query video looking at
videos that were most frequently watched
with the query video and also other
approaches the focus of this paper isn't
on candidate generation it's really on
the second step of once we have a few
hundred candidates how do we rank the
ones that we think are going to be the
best options
cool so um in this ranking problem
uh the input is again the information
about the query video information about
the candidate video and also information
about the user uh and and other context
and so in particular
um those input features are showing the
bottom yellow boxes so features of the
Korean candidate video and features of
the user in the context that's going to
be passed into the neural network as
input
and then there's the output so the
output of this model is going to try to
Output measures of Engagement and
satisfaction with the candid video
and so intuitively if we want to be able
to
um in this case their goal is to try to
figure out things that have higher rank
and so things that have if you're able
to predict the engagement and
satisfaction you'll be able to rank the
videos
and so more concretely what engagement
means is they're going to build they're
going to be predicting binary
classification tasks like whether or not
they click on the video
um and also regression tasks that relate
to the time spent watching the candidate
video
and satisfaction is going to correspond
to things like clicking the like button
on the candidate video and also the
rating that they give to that video
which I believe is um from surveys
um one thing that's interesting is once
they have the model output they're
trading a model to Output these things
from the input features that's what the
machine learning problem is
um to get the ranking score they
actually manually they manually weight a
combination of these different
predictions and tune the weights of on
these different things in a manual
process based on what they think seems
to do the best
um cool so I guess question for you
before we move on to the approach
um so the objective is to predict kind
of Engagement and satisfaction I'm
curious do these objectives seem
reasonable and what are some issues that
might come up with um with the
subjective
yeah
so you might have um kind of missing
data that comes up because people might
not respond to a survey or they might
like maybe people like a video but they
don't click like for example
yeah
like a video may be like sorted
maybe you didn't like buttons
yeah so things like time spent if you
have a longer video maybe it'll
people will spend more time watching
that than short videos um and so you may
want to kind of control for that
yeah
buttons I mean
it's possible that there is a lot of
Engagement but uh satisfaction data is
to do this
yeah so you're going to have data
imbalance you like the surveys for
example you're gonna have a lot less
survey data maybe a lot less
um data about whether or not users click
likes click like or not but more dense
data about engagement
yeah a video that a user engages with a
lot they might not necessarily like
we're showing action that would like a
negative review but they ask you just
like status issues for them yeah so
people
um people might watch something but not
actually like what they're watching
yeah
something like self-reinforcing and
group cycling but if a user's creating
another video and then you show them
more of the same type let me just keep
clicking on the same thing but they you
know actually lose your way to content
you're just restricting what they're
seeing yeah so feedback loops so once
you start deploying the system and
actually have it collect data then that
might affect what people are clicking on
and um and that might uh you might have
like that might lead to a data
distribution that is a little bit skewed
and difficult to make Generations on
yeah well this is an editorialization
but from like a social perspective
you're optimizing for wasting people's
time
yeah awesome so um the the point was
that maybe optimizing for a time spent
on YouTube is not uh good for society
and I I really like this response
because last time I asked people last
year I asked people this question and
everyone was pointing out technical
challenges and not pointing out actual
like ethical or societal challenges with
this so actually thinking about
the subjective not just from the
standpoint of a technical standpoint but
also like what should YouTube be
optimizing for I think is really
important
yeah
they want to make sure that
so along with the exploration is also
some exploration topics like some
readers might not be that popular but
later for the platform this is more
diversity and like solve these kind of
problems they might not read that and do
yeah so I mean in general these metrics
are very short-term metrics and
um actually factoring in what's going to
happen in the long term
um and whether or not videos that like
and yeah exactly it's like sort of like
what that feedback process will look
like
um is really important for
um for their business model and also in
general for
um
for actually serving stuff that people
want to see
cool um for the sake of time
um let's kind of go into actually how
they do this
um so the basic option this is really
the Baseline is a multi-head
architecture where they pass as input
the input features into a shared bottom
layer and then and then have these top
specific heads that are predicting
different engagement and satisfaction
measures
um they found that this can harm
learning when the correlation between
tasks is low and they're actually going
to try to improve upon this architecture
right here by actually allowing the
model to share a little bit less between
the tasks
um and so what they choose to do is they
use an architecture which they refer to
as the multi-gate mixture of experts
modeled and what essentially this is
going to look like is there's still
going to be one shared bottom layer but
there's going to be a number of
different experts and it's going to try
to actually have the model choose how it
uses those experts each of those kind of
parts of the model
based on what it finds works well
um and essentially what this will try to
do is to allow different parts of the
network to specialize for different
tasks while also having it figure out
whether it's useful to reuse some
components
so specifically what this looks like is
um after the shared bottom layer you
have a um a set of expert neural
networks so these are different modules
denoted by I
and
for a given set of features for input X
and task K we're going to
um
try to basically predict which expert we
want to use for that input and for that
task
um and so the way that we're going to do
this is we're going to pass this through
a softmax function you can think of a
softmax function as something that's
trying to predict a one hot Vector but
in a soft way so that we can
differentiate through it so in
particular this is going to give us a
probability distribution over the
experts that we want to use
and then once we have this probability
distribution we're going to weight the
predictions of the experts by these
probabilities
um and then once we have the output of
this this weighted expert outputs will
then compute the output from there
um and in their experiments they
implemented this in tensorflow with tpus
they trained on videos in temporal order
because they have a ton of video data
um and so they're going to be running
training continuously to consume the
newly arriving data and then they did
online a b testing in comparison to a
production system
and then here also model computational
efficiency matters as well
and then the results they found that uh
this mixture of extra models with eight
experts is able to do three percent
better on satisfaction metrics and 0.45
percent better on engagement metrics
which is actually pretty substantial
given the scale of this kind of system
um and this is in comparison to a shared
bottom Network and you can also
um look at how it's utilizing the
different experts for different tasks
and we see that there is some
specialization for example expert 7 is
used a lot for satisfaction task four
but there's also a considerable amount
of sharing for example expert five is
used for a lot of the tasks
um
cool so we're basically out of time so
to recap the lecture we talked about
multitask learning and how it learns a
neural network conditioned on zi we
talked about how the choice of the task
waiting is going to affect the
prioritization of the tasks and we also
talked about how conditioning on zi will
affect how the parameters are shared and
if You observe negative transfer it's
helpful to share less and if You observe
positive transfer it's helpful to share
but potentially try sharing more or if
You observe overfitting
um so really these are the key design
choices when it comes to multitask
Learning Systems
um and next time we'll start to cover
transfer learning and get to some cool
meta learning topics as well